well here's the thing we did the hardest
thing first right like
everyone from oscar hammerstein to
stephen sondheim will tell you
don't start with an original musical
[Music]
i would say 80 of musicals are
adaptations of other things even the
masterpieces westside story
is based on romeo and juliet gypsy is
based on a memoir
and so we did the hardest thing first
every early version of in the heights
was like a bunch of characters in search
of a
storyline and in turn in search of what
what story we really are focused on
telling and
when kiara kind of came aboard she said
this is about a community
changing and that allows
us to really focus on one
the notion of home uh which for first
generation folks like kiara and i when
your parents are born uh
somewhere else and you grow up here
maybe speaking a different language like
home is a trickier question
uh this is not uh you know it's not
dorothy of kansas
is home it's it's a different thing
every character is struggling with some
version of that the old characters the
younger characters
um and so so that was really the thing
that began to focus the story lines and
get us to
the version that got us to broadway and
then you know she really
brilliantly wrote the screenplay um and
just
was so smart about updating businessman
richard then nina's daddy
tiger woods and i on the link so he's my
caddy you know we knew we would have to
cut songs but
the way in which she cut songs with such
care
um and in a way that you never lost the
essence of
the the score and the storytelling and
then gave other storylines prominence
there's without spoiling anything there
is a major character
uh who is undocumented um that is the
front-page
conversation for for latinos living in
the united states
right now and i think it's again like
it's like what art at its best can do
which is if you walk
a mile in someone else's shoes through a
piece of art like you can't go back to
the issue
the same way like knowing this character
is struggling with this
like makes it much harder to otherize
people in the conversation that happens
so much
uh around uh immigration and then like i
mean there's the
central like framing device you know
like wasabi is telling us the story and
he's on the beach like so
already fans of the original music are
like
it's it's just so smart
i'm i'm a big fan of musicals
and i want to learn everything i can
from the ones i love
and we really took a page and a half
out of the fiddler on the roof structure
right
sounds crazy now here is uh tevye
and he's welcoming you to his village of
venateka and he's going to introduce
them to you in sort of concentric
circles
here is my family here are the families
and the roles we play
here are the special types in our
village here are the outsiders in our
village
and like here we are and so we kind of
do a similar thing here like
usnavi's artevia and then we're going to
meet abuela
who's the closest person to him then
we're going to meet the businesses on
the block like here comes kevin here
comes
um the salon ladies um and then here
come like
and then here comes benny and then here
comes uh vanessa
um so it's and and then with every
chorus kind of expanding
um from and we're seeing everyone's
journeys really to his store
it's from waking up in the morning to
like what you need to do to survive
um and and getting out the door and
getting that cup of coffee and
and starting your day um and then of
course john
m two like super sizes that right like
from the moment
um the foot scratches the sewer grate
like a record player
you realize like the moment songs start
we are in a heightened reality
and we can go as big as these characters
dreams
you know i was just so thrilled with
the way he introduced everyone it's it's
like
i don't know it's sort of all hands on
deck it reminds me of in hamilton like
we use rewind do we use fast forward do
we use multiple narrators like
and john does that too like john like
has usnavi look right at the camera for
hey y'all good morning
like he like he gives us like the full
like spike lee behind the feet
like up to the salon ladies as they're
crossing the street like he kind of
throws the kitchen sink at it
and in in the most glorious way because
you are not meeting
one character you are meeting a
community in motion
the shot that makes me cry every time is
there's a shot of this superintendent
uh with a mop who goes like this at the
end of the second course
that was the superintendent of the
building we were in
and he was facilitating things for us to
shoot in the lobby and john was like
hold on a second stand over here like
and just like threw him into the movie
and it to me it's one of the most
affecting
images in it and so you know i i really
appreciate that about john is that
he plans and he's a meticulous planner
but then he also allows for
whatever magic is happening to happen
so for me the fun is usnavi is super
um methodical when he's talking to his
friends and then when he talks to the
woman he loves like it all goes out the
window right so like
he's pun when it starts it's silly when
we get into these crazy hypotheticals
you really want some bread then go ahead
create a set that goes
like it's rhyming six times on the line
and then
vanessa goes what are you doing and
suddenly it's like
what am i doing what am i doing it takes
half of that cast
and like he's trying to find the beat um
like it's it's really like he's carrying
all his words and then vanessa looks at
him and he
drops them all like it's harry potter
spitting out the pumpkin juice in
in movie four um and so and then like
accidentally saying like
i love you very much okay let's take it
over to sonny yo we're 96
000. i finally fixed house sunny and i
always point this out when i'm talking
to
school groups who are performing in
heights he's the youngest character
and he's the only character who wants to
better his community he doesn't say i'm
going to go party i don't want to go
you know buy a house he says like i'm
going to fix this neighborhood and i'm
going to change the
world and everyone's response is oh
you're so cute
um so it's sort of like the bitter
sweetness of that like
this kid has not lost his ideals for a
second
and it's like nice dreaming kid
and so you know the fun in writing that
one like
in my first draft writing for robin was
like amazing because
robin jesus is a force of nature but
those lyrics
um politicians be hating racism in this
nation has gone from latent to blatant
um i think when i first wrote those
what i was thinking about in the news
was like
the governor of arizona it was like jan
brewer and she was introducing like
some insane policy where uh anyone
suspected of immigrants had to carry
their
immigration papers on them at all times
and we were like what country are we in
um and i remember performing that in
arizona um and we'd always get this kind
of
huge response and like two little like
white ladies would like walk out
like at that song like every night um
and and so that's what it was sort of in
regards to
i had no idea um of the past
administration was
was going to be on its way and it would
make um you know
who would begin his campaign by
demonizing
uh immigrants and making them into this
horrible other
uh in his his rhetoric so it did go from
layton to blatant to like
virulently blatant and and hateful uh
and i wish that lyric
were less relevant uh than it is
if i won the lotto tomorrow will i well
i mean the beginning
the first verse is really like again
that's the most freestyle of supreme
influenced in terms of like
he's finding the rhymes as he goes and
he like it's
if i won the lotto tomorrow well i know
like i really wanted it to feel like
he's just grabbing the words as they
come to him and then when he comes in
with that hook
i really think that's the that's really
where like i
dialed into chris jackson's voice and
what it can do
and kind of never let go um that you
know for real though is a chris
jacksonism
you know he's like for real though
that's what's up those are like the two
things those are the two verbal ticks he
will say the most
so then to turn that into like music for
real though
and then building off that was the first
time i really sort of stopped
writing benny as this fictional
character that lived in my head and
started writing to chris jackson's
uh strengths and then of course like
corey hawkins is just
so incredible uh in this movie and
and the way he sort of carries that
spirit forward is really fantastic
well listen check 123 is like a call and
response as old as hip-hop itself i
remember
trying to find the original and i just
went down a wormhole because everyone
who uses it doesn't
credit it um but i remember think i
think i first heard it on fuji on a
fuji's vocab remix
um and then uh black star and then
krs one um with boogie down productions
that check one two three so like
i let you know i like them kind of
bringing a little more old-school
like 80s hip-hop flavor to their thing
and yeah and then like they bring in
like the full reggaeton beat and then
like there's no going back
um it's it's really it's really uh fun
uh it's really fun to see all of them
together
[Music]
vanessa really became the character she
became once i wrote it won't be long now
and i wrote that between 2003-2004
um it was and it's interesting because
it was
the only it was one of the times where
nothing was really happening on the show
at all
we had done these presentations we'd had
a little interest
but nothing happened like it was just
sort of like
okay i guess we'll keep writing it until
people are
interested enough to try to put this on
and there was a year where i really did
nothing but write that one song
um and and now looking back on it of
course that's the song i wrote because
it's all about yearning
it's all about the distance between your
dream
and where you're sitting um i was a
substitute teacher i had quit
full-time teaching because i thought in
the heights was going so well and then
nothing happened
uh and i was there and so so vanessa
became this sort of
really yearning character and she just
brings that into 96 000.
it's she doesn't come in with like i'm
gonna party she comes in like
i'm out of here you guys and
usnoff he responds accordingly but she
does bring that sort of eponine
yearning into what is like until then
like a really like
fun vibrant hip-hop number
for opening night of in the heights on
broadway i gave many gonzalez a cd
with the 16 songs that were almost brief
before i finally got to breathe
it her songs were always the hardest to
write and i think
it's because they were so close to the
bone and
um someone pointed this out to me in an
interview yesterday like
everyone's everyone else's songs are a
little more complicated
and nina's are like breathe let me
listen to my block
when the sun goes like they're so and
it's hard work to get
that simple and the first draft of
of breathe didn't have the bridge it was
just the verses
um and that's how it existed
off-broadway and then between
off-broadway and broadway i
created the bridge which i think is the
reason the song
speaks to people the way it does it's
it's it's these it's the neighborhood
singing in spanish
[Music]
and she's translating them um she's
literally
singing what they're saying to her in
her response they're not worried about
me um they are all counting on me to
succeed like
every line in spanish and again first of
all like how much
is that our lives when we are the code
switchers in our community like
we're translating on behalf of our
community but it's
also it's they're all so
sure and the only person who isn't sure
is her um
and that is very real um
and uh and it's
it's it's heartbreaking it's definitely
heartbreaking for me to watch because
our friend doreen montalvo who sang that
part on broadway
sings the role in the movie and i'm so
grateful
that we just never imagined anyone else
doing it and we get to sort of
immortalize
uh her her incredible voice and and
and incredible smile in that moment
[Music]
[Applause]
it was sort of the like if you can get
it done it's in the movie and if it's
not it's not in the movie
um and we got it done we got an eight
minute
musical number with the entire cast done
in one day
and when we yelled cut and no one
stopped dancing and singing because they
had their flags in the air and they were
so
proud um it was it was really one of
those like and i was
perched on a fire escape uh watching the
whole thing
and i will never forget that as long as
i live i'm fast forwarding in my head to
getting to premiere this thing at the
united palace on 175th street
in the heart of washington heights i
cannot wait for that moment
you